OF THE LAST FOUR, AN EXCELLENT
OUTSIDE , HE CHIPPED
TRANSITIONING AS WELL.
THEY HAVE THE DEFENSE ON
ANDREI VASILEVSKIY HAD A GREAT
CHANCE EARLY ON IN THE PERIOD.
HE'S COMING DOWNHILL FROM THE
BLUE LINE.
HERE COMES THE PRESSURE OFF
STEVEN STAMKOS TRIES TO TAKE IT
OUT WIDE.
HE IS E KINGS GO RIGHT BACK TO
IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE.
A NONEVENT STYLE DEFENSEMEN.
>> HE IS NOT SWOOPING ALL OF TO
>> NOW THAT IS OFF OPPOSITE
SIDE.
BY QUICK.
>> STEVEN STAMKOS IS PLAYING
WELL.
HE HAS ON.
>> THAT WAS GOOD DEFENSIVE PLAY
AS WELL, IN FRONT OF THE NET.
THE KINGS HAVE BEEN BORIS
ACROSS TO VICTOR
HEDMAN.
HE PUTWE HAVE A A KNOCKS IT SIX
HE HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE IN THIS O
TONIGHT.
THE KINGSTHE DEFENSE.
GOES UTIME THE LIGHTNING
WENT OVER TIME WITH
THE BACKEND IS WAY TO THE
NET.
THAT WAS  ROSS COLTON GOING A N
HE TAKES IT OUT FRONT.
ANTHONY
HE LEAVES IT FOR VIKTOR
ARVIDSSON.
HE CUTS